how you been brother good to see you hi
jason hey chim off
you're you're healed from your spanking
at poker last week
well that was not fun that was not fun
jake allen tilt
but there was some good wine and it was
good to have you back
j cal is a mouthy little guy for the
last 18 months while i was
healing myself i was not at the poker
game he was running over everybody
verbally
and i showed up and for the first 15
minutes all i did was literally tear
everybody a new one just randomly i mean
just destroying everything the doordash
guy was destroyed everybody was in a
puddle
it was spreading uh yeah but yeah and
then jake out lost when jacob loses he
shuts up he clams up
i guess i'm really quiet i get very
frustrated with myself when i make bad
plays
i don't get frustrated by randomness i
don't mind getting sucked out on it's i
know when i did something stupid
try to get better but speaking about
doing stupid stuff hey how's the last
year been for you
last year has really i mean honestly it
is facetious but there's been a lot of
changes it has been the most incredible
year of my life
yeah 18 the last 18 months has probably
been the most profound 18 months of my
life
well let's get into it a bit um i i
remember
you were here a couple years ago and
obviously you've spoken our events been
on the pod
a whole bunch of times you're one of the
highest rated speakers we've ever had
because you're always very candid
you're also very ambitious and i watched
social capital go from being what i
would call the classic series a
and seed stage fund and then you added
an ipo a
and then you added a growth fund and a
hedge fund and this grand vision started
to emerge
and now it seems like you've deprecated
all that and gotten back to the roots
what happened why how did you wind up
here
um well it was a it was a lot of me just
trying to figure out who i was
as a person and um trying to just have
confidence in myself and not be so
completely insecure
and a lot of my success was always
rooted in my
this massive inferiority complex that i
had
uh not white not rich not well educated
blah blah blah blah blah
you know you you pack on all this
baggage over so many years
but it can be really instrumental in
motivating you and it was very
motivating for me
and so it worked for a really long time
but then
i started to fall for a lot of the
trappings of what some of that
had given me meaning you know when i was
in the in sort of years six seven and
eight of social capital i
frankly got distracted i started out
with this mission of wanting to
work on really important companies and
ideas and work with founders for
you know decades and i thought that's
what would be
necessary to really solve some important
problems in the world
and so in order to do that i thought
well let me put in a lot of my own money
and then
i'll establish control and all of that
was true but i still
felt for it next thing you know i was
flying around london paris
new york abu dhabi riyadh and you're
meeting with all these people that you
think are important
and as with a lot of things what happens
in mythology is when you get close to
the myth it disintegrates and you
realize
that there's really not much there and
that and oftentimes the emperor has no
clothes i think about
all of the entrepreneurs you aspire to
meet that you think are exceptional
i probably know all of them you would
probably and i if we rated one to ten
would give them very different scores
because they're just normal people and
they have the same weaknesses and
you know faults and trappings that we
all do
and so in any event the point is i got
to a place where i was like
nothing is working for me meaning i was
richer than i had ever been or
more well-known or more notoriety and i
was
thoroughly unhappy and you got the nba
team
or a piece of it a big piece of it the
warriors that won multiple championships
and that was mind-blowing for both of us
to hang out at warrior games or take him
to vegas
yeah have fun and it was kind of
mind-blowing but at the end of the day
you you kind of drifted away from what
you were good at i was i was not happy i
mean well at the core of it i was just
fundamentally not happy and so how does
it manifest
it manifests in the following ways one i
was very emotionally unavailable
to my family i was unemotional to my
friends unavailable i was basically
absent
building a business that i didn't want
to be building meaning
constantly on the road constantly on a
plane beating up my body beating up my
mind
um and it took me in these last 18
months the courage to just say enough
and basically what it was was me
seeking out my own therapy and
all of a sudden i realized there is so
much baggage that relates to the trauma
that i had when i was a kid
and i had always talked about it but i'd
never really dealt with it
you know and there's something and i
would just put a very fine point on it
which is a lot of us deal with baggage
and trauma as for my childhood
in my specific case what it left was a
deep gaping hole where i felt completely
unworthy and not whole
boom that's the end that's there's a lot
of stuff that comes up to it but that's
the takeaway that's the punch line
immigrant family alcoholic father
abusive psychologically and physically
and all of us have versions of all of
this trauma the point is that i
felt 0 0 0 um
sense of worth and so i chased everybody
else's definition of what worthy and
successful should mean
and i did a good [ __ ] job about it
too yeah you were faking it pretty good
there for a while
i mean like you know i could dunk with
the best of them i mean truly
but it was not making me happy and it
took me into my early 40s to say
what is what is going to change this
this sort of lingering burning sensation
in my stomach
um and so i just went off to fix these
things and so
it caused a ton of dramatic change both
personally in my life and professionally
in my life
and professionally the most important
thing is i said i'm building somebody
else's company
and i'm sure all of you guys founders
have felt that moment where it's like
am i building the thing that i want or
am i building the thing that somebody
else wants
well these investors will tell you
they'll give me money if you do this
this this and this
some of it feels core some of it feels
doesn't doesn't feel core
well guess what what happens when
somebody tells you to mouth i'll give
you five billion dollars you just need
to do this this and this
and i'm like i don't need your 5 billion
but then my partner's like no we want
theirs too
and yours and if you don't do it we will
quit or this and that and all of a
sudden it's like
the business of being in a business
takes over
and then you forget what you were there
for in the first place
mission goes out the door values go out
the door the way in which you made
decisions go out the door your risk
tolerance changes
again i think what i went through a lot
of founders go through
and there have to be these moments where
you basically circle the wagons and say
enough's enough or you capitulate
and that was my choice i had to either
capitulate
or i had to basically rip it all down
and
and that's thank you for sharing number
one i think it's
really honest uh sort of assessment i
think sure
um
it's fascinating to me because we knew
each other before you were at facebook
before you had money um and you were
at aol i was just so my company there
and we were just two
dorky kids trying to and probably shared
a lot of dna
both of us you know didn't have ideal
childhoods both of us
just trying to make it their way in the
world and then you got to this point
where you felt like
hmm i'm not happy anymore and
why am i trying to impress these other
people
what's the core of that why were you
trying to be part of this like big grand
hedge fund world because you were so
good at it you went to that
what's that conference in new york where
you picked i was soon no i i was you
were on the stage
we were running i was running until we
shut it down uh
top two percent hedge fund in the world
and i was doing it
an hour a week yeah
i mean it was an enormous amount of
money but i literally spent an hour a
week doing that job and it was a top 2
hedge fund right and you're invited to
speak at the
hedge fund of hedge fund conference and
it's intoxicating because you're
speaking and i spoke about box and they
show a little ticker
and box literally rips up and it's up
like 50
from where it was and you think look at
the positive impact i had
on all these employees just by opening
my mouth and blathering on
yeah it's a very intoxicating thing but
at the core of it is
why because everybody wants to feel
validated
and in the absence of being able to
validate oneself from within
you will seek others to validate you and
what's dangerous about the world
of that we live in which is
entrepreneurship and technology
is that it is so in the bullseye of
everybody else now
everybody wants to be in it around it on
top of it
under it associated with it funding it
being a part of it employed by it
employing i mean
all of it is true and so it's a very
intoxicating
shiny object that people want to have
around them and so they will use
whatever devices that they have
to co-opt that and in my case it was a
very practical equation which is
these governments these pension funds
these family offices these very famous
important people have all this money
they're like chamath come
here blah blah blah and you start to
fall for it
and i fell for it and i fell for it for
a long time
um and then eventually again the
mythology starts to
wane and you realize you know again i'm
sure you've
had this oh this investor who i led into
my cap table who i thought was going to
solve all my problems turns out
he's just as [ __ ] stupid as i am
it turns out wait a minute if i don't
solve this problem no one's going to
solve this problem
oh wait a minute this person that i
hired on my team who was supposed to
solve all my problems
not so much if i don't help solve it
it's not going to get stopped
i mean it all goes back to this
fundamental belief in oneself
and it was much easier for me um to have
that in
in small doses in small things very
difficult for me to have it in big doses
and the things that mattered
until i went back and i fixed the
core toolbox that i use to build myself
up in the morning and that took a long
time
and now what is social capital the
partnership's been dropped
i it will be what it always has been
you know i i think like look when i read
articles
and you see all the negative press and
it was so weird because i'm about to
publish our annual investor letter and
i'll just preview it to you for a second
our returns are bananas okay
i've made more in the last eight years
compared to the s p
than buffett did in the first eight
years of berkshire
buffett did a thousand points of alpha i
did 1800 points of alpha my returns are
double buffets
and that's if you it and that's not
including bitcoin amazon and the
warriors which i did off balance sheet
in my own money
so there was nothing to numerically
complain about
the job that we were doing we were doing
but
i was so empty because i was like we're
not doing the job that we were supposed
to be doing
which was investing in healthcare
education not even in investing the
point is like
you need to be there to like basically
take a stand on issues
and i have the bully pulpit to do it we
had the capital to do it but we weren't
doing it in as much
of a way that we should have been
climate change still ripping away
unabated
what is anybody doing about it you know
education is eroding at the seams what
is anybody really doing about it
drug costs through the ceiling the
united states healthcare system
worse and worse and worse every year
even though we spend more and more and
more
what is anybody really doing about it
and the answer is
not as much as it needs to be done yeah
and certainly
and so that's not a conversation of
investing or
irrs or blah blah blah it's about ideas
and it's about people and it's about
drawing a line in the sand and doing
things and
i was good at that for a while and then
i stopped focusing on it
and so what we are today is an attempt
to get back to
where we started and what we should have
always been which is
really interesting ways of solving very
difficult problems
that if they are solved matter in the
world
a very long-term byproduct of that will
be more capital
i suspect enormous amounts way more than
a traditional investing job will do
but that's a by-product because when you
measure and quantify the absolute value
of progress
it's way more enormous than measuring
the absolute value of discounted cash
flows
and that's what people don't get and
they get lost in all of this stuff and
particularly now
when tech is so hot and so interesting
and blah blah blah
it's easy to lose sight of what's really
important so we are
permanent capital starting with two
billion of my own money
we are investing as much as we need for
as long as we want in the things that
are important
and what's great about that is that
there's no lps
there's no decision making that isn't
just about a group of us that are very
technical and product oriented can
ask and answer extremely important
technical questions and then we have an
entire network of people around us that
is wholly different than what they were
partnerships with the salk institute
partnerships with mit partnerships with
xerox park partnerships with 40 postdocs
doing all kinds of really interesting
research in the world so we can learn
from these folks who are really on the
ground selflessly trying to solve
important issues in the world
and when we can translate when we can
learn then we can go off and do
interesting things and
those companies now jason you know that
we really started in fund one
are doing exceptionally well you know i
i used to do this thing every quarter
where i would ask the team
hey guys tell me all of our companies
what you think the exits will be
and i always used it for two reasons one
to validate that
whatever they thought was gonna happen
wasn't and two was who was obvious and
should be fired first
because it's very easy for some numskull
to basically say oh well this one with
the most revenue is worth the most money
right that's easy but how hard is it for
someone to actually project forward what
the real value of a market in a business
should be
and how things should be changed and
manipulated and morphed to max value
and i find that there were a few people
who were consistently really good at it
they're still here you know and so i'm
happy to be around folks that can
actually see the forest from the trees
this way
like you know i remember we put in a few
million dollars
around this idea of small-scale
satellites
and this entrepreneur she was superb and
she could not get a meeting
and what's so lucky for us is we met her
after an entire you know fakata process
where all the traditional folks were
like no
and we gave her what she needed etc etc
and she is literally off to the races
off to space launching an entire
constellation
that will basically become like an
alternative low-cost version of the
internet
mega huge multi-trillion dollar close to
trillion dollar companies talk about it
they blather on about it they do
[ __ ] keynotes about it she's done it
and she's done it with three million
bucks that's bananas
yeah and so i need to be around people
like her
the hype has gotten a little bit out of
control it's out of control yeah
it's out of control what what do you
think the end is what is the end game
here well we're in we're
we are make no mistake uh
well you are i'm out because i sold like
but you guys are in
the middle of an enormous uh
multivariate kind of ponzi scheme and so
let me explain that to you because it's
important for you to understand
you get courted by investors okay
these are not people writing checks out
of their own balance sheet they're doing
a job with other people's money
and for that they get one thing that's
obvious which is
a yearly fee
and then something that's non-obvious
which is a part of the gains if what you
do works
okay right everybody understands that
that's how a fund that invests in you
works
that fund is getting paid fees every
year
and then carry at the back end if it
works okay
they come to you they're like we want to
partner with you you're the best we're
going to help you're so awesome
have a fleece vest
it has our logo on it you know
we backed blah blah company you know
what right that's the whole that's the
basic that's the pitch
um so you say yes
and then they give you i'm just going to
make up a number a million bucks
then you go to your first board meeting
how fast are you growing
how many of you have had these
discussions how fast are you growing
okay grow faster how many of you have
had that discussion grow faster
okay most of you that raised your hand
well it would it would probably shock
you to know that almost 40 cents of
every venture dollar right now goes
right back into the hands of google
facebook and amazon
what do you think is happening there do
you think that's all profitable growth
no that's there to fund
your superficial growth
just because the entrepreneur or the vc
gives you a million dollars and tells
you to grow faster
do you have better product market fit in
that moment
no you're doing what you're told to do
which is to take their money and make
the company grow
superficially grow then what do they do
they turn around to their buddies and
say
look at this thing it's growing you
should do the bee
and then they come into a board meeting
they're like guys i think we should
raise a b
how many of that how many times i mean
you may not be late enough in that stage
but you've gone through this jason i
mean you went through with the best of
them sequoia
no comment um great firm fantastic firm
great people tremendous tremendous
um
stay in your lane
i know you're burning it all down just
don't burn down my house in the process
okay
i'm still building my house i know i
know you
try to keep up here it's not easy being
in the passenger seat this time
this thing have airbags okay so anyways
so then that you know they're like hey
you should raise a b
um and some different firm of which
they're all buddies
do the b mark it up four five x
now what's happened fund a their returns
look genius
now it's all on paper but it looks
amazing
right fund b comes into the board
meeting now
hey how fast are you growing
you got to grow faster okay
now 40 cents of every dollar there goes
into facebook and google
and amazon right and you're buying even
more unprofitable growth
it's not even clear that those ltvs and
those cacs make any sense
doesn't matter you've been told to grow
so you're growing you're doing your job
did your product market fit actually
change in that moment probably not
but you continue to pump money into
those things
and then the series b investor says hmm
we should raise a series c we're running
out of money well of course you are
because 40 cents of every dollar just
went back into the hands of facebook
google and amazon
they introduced it to another buddy that
buddy is like yeah this looks great
boom fire the money in now a
has an even better markup b has a markup
c has a basis and is like hey
how fast are you growing maybe you
should grow faster okay
now meanwhile somewhere between the b
and the c round
the guy who runs fun day is like i
should raise a second fund
i'm pretty good at this
and goes to a bunch of investors and
says look at my irr
they're amazing isn't this amazing and
the investor's like
yeah this is amazing here here's more
money
and then now he or she goes and finds
another batch and starts the process
again
and then somewhere between the c and the
d the b guys are like
i'm pretty good at this this is easier
than i i should raise a second fund
maybe i'll make it a slightly bigger
fund i should be doing bigger checks
raises a b right raises fund too finds
funday's batch of second companies and
says hey let's work together again we
are good at this together
on and on down the line this is what's
happening now
so when you wake up every day and you
read
a newsletter and you notice
that umpteen companies are getting
funded for every single idea
and then that the quantum of dollars are
going up and that all of a sudden you're
reading about investors you've
never ever heard of
that is what something like this looks
like played out in real life so you have
the cream of the crop
who will still do a good job but who now
have to raise
larger and larger funds they own less
and less of the companies the returns
are not as good
and then you have everybody else who's
chasing chasing chasing and playing this
sort of hot potato game
hoping to raise a fund and then a second
fund and then third fund
and then the biggest thing happens which
is you all be
this that whole industry that services
you guys theoretically services you guys
are no longer about your success because
your success
is about their carry and they couldn't
give
a [ __ ] they care about fees
right and it's not very difficult to get
out of google spreadsheet and figure out
at how many dollars
right does two percent of those dollars
divided by the five or six partners at
that firm are greater than
their share of profits for you at some
number of exits and then you wonder why
they're more concerned about how much
money you're spending on facebook google
and amazon
you so if somebody builds up five or six
of these 500 million dollar funds they
get to two three four much less
much less jason yeah i mean if you if
you even have 500 million under
management and you're collecting
two percent a year it's 10 million bucks
you know it's
three let's just say there's four or
five partners you're making a million
dollars a year
over 10 years think of how much you've
made 10 million
and think of how much the has to be
i mean you're you you look stupid but
you are not stupid
uh but think of how much money the fund
would have to be
you know net of expenses net of all of
this stuff for you to pay back
it's super complicated now yeah and so
my point is
the incentives in this industry are the
most out of whack they've ever been
it's a bit of a charade so my point is i
looked at our portfolio
we have some incredible businesses we
have things that are really meaningful
in the world we have both
and i'm like it's time to take my tips
off the table sorry
ciao you know so and i would rather sit
there and wait with an enormous balance
sheet of capital
find the really really good companies
that need the money
and then also wait for some of this air
to get out of the balloon
find a point where like the charade gets
exposed
feels like it's a little bit bubbly but
great companies are coming out of this
some of them are the ones you've
invested in slack intercom
that's what i'm saying i think we are we
are very fortunate to be in
uh a bunch of companies that are going
to be iconic legacy businesses
what i'm saying is the next you know 250
million dollar check i want to write
i'm more likely to just buy a company
outright or give that 250 million
dollars to a company
that isn't looking to raise it but
rather it's like a
you know their last post was at 20
million and say hey listen
uh what you're doing is really kick ass
it's probably going to take 25 years
here's 250 million based on these
milestones check in with me when you
need the extra money
because quite honestly like i think
that's a healthier way i think you'll
be more impactful and i think again for
me i will not be a part of this charade
anymore
and i think the charade is dangerous and
it's particularly dangerous to these
companies
it's very very dangerous to you as
founders because again
at some point the whole grow grow grow
at all costs
runs out of juice you can no longer
acquire at a certain point
profitably in google facebook and amazon
right your ltvs will get out of whack
right your um gross margin positivity
all of a sudden gross margin negativity
i mean forget about net profitability
these are fundamentally broken business
concepts they don't work
they only work if the money never stops
but the money never stops
until as much time as people can raise
new funds and that's predicated on
people marking up old deals
you see how this whole thing like at no
point is there anything that comes back
to you the entrepreneur that says
what's your true core product market fit
and is it working
it's not part of the conversation that
is extremely dangerous
so it's i can't prognosticate and pick a
time
that's not the point but i think the
point is that there has to be
much more sobriety in terms of how
companies grow and you know like i've
now thought to myself my gosh i would
love
to grow and find a business that can be
there growing
20 to 25 a year for the next 15 years
that violates all the mechanics and all
the gymnastics within a venture fund
it's like growth 400 because we know 400
eventually decays to 12 percent a year
but they don't care by the time you're
growing at 12 a year because by the time
400 became 200 became 100 became 50
they've raised two more funds they've
marked up the rest of their deals
they've made their fees ciao
so how does a founder protect against
grow slow
okay
grow real gross long we're real gross
jeff bezos grew amazon and i mean this
what's so bananas like none of us go
back and look at the people we really
want to be like
i'd like to be like that guy he's in his
50s
he's ripped he's rich as [ __ ] and he's a
genius
yeah okay that guy basically grew at 25
a year for [ __ ] 25 years i'm sorry
but that's dropped the mic
level stuff there that's not
i don't know what's going on you know
you can't come out of the gate too fast
and i've learned that the hard way so
that's
one really important thing i have a very
simple thing i draw on the box now to my
team i'm like
here's a two by two matrix draw it out
if you want okay
this x-axis is capital light
capital heavy x-axis
the y-axis is obvious non-obvious
wherever you are you want to be whether
you're obvious or non-obvious
you want to be in that capital light
column
think of where venture excels
venture excels in obvious meets capital
heavy
look at scooters it's not it's not
to make fun scooters is an exceptionally
obvious business model right you'd say
well
we had planes on charter 25 years ago
through net jets
we eventually had smaller planes on
charter then we had buses on charter
then we had
limousines on charter then we had cars
on charter then we had cheaper cars on
charter than we were pooling cars
then we had bicycles i mean you
literally did not have to be
as smart as you to take that trail of
breadcrumbs and say well what's the
quantum of transport that's smaller than
a bicycle but greater than your feet
rollerblades rollerblades just slittered
all over
uh san francisco just roller blades
everywhere put your feet in
see what happens yeah could be anything
in there could be anything in there
need hypodermic needles anything human
dog yeah you know by the way when you
become mayor and fix this town
i'm gonna move back here that's my
commitment to you i like it
mayorjason.com approves um
so so basically like but think about
that right but now think about how much
money has gone into that category
billions
and in and hundreds of millions and the
the delta of time
that those companies have existed 18
months 24 months
but again obvious capital heavy
why because it pays off the charade get
it in there fire it in
buy some ads grow so fast get somebody
else put some more money in fire some
ads buy some grove blah blah blah
jesus christ i mean like is that is that
how great businesses get built
in my opinion probably not
then you have people like elon and he's
like well
i'm gonna do the other thing which is
like capital heavy non-obvious
and basically unless you're as smart as
he is it's
the dumbest thing to do rocket ships
rocket ships
cars electric cars power walls then i
would say there's the rest of us and i
would say
non-obvious or obvious you're not going
to know a priori
but capital heavy capital light you can
control
and i love this idea of things like for
example we're incubating a company right
now
which i just absolutely fundamentally
love it is in a non-obvious space
that is extremely capital heavy and our
approach
is basically unbelievably obvious to us
because we come from the internet
and it's exceptionally capitalized think
about it as
you know it takes two billion dollars to
launch a product
and you know that two billion dollars
because of how much it costs
you need like 20 000 customers and we go
off and we find those 20 000 customers
for two thousand dollars and we're like
two billion dollars is spent to acquire
these what's going what
and so but instead what we said was
let's just seed it
with 50k it's kind of working let's put
in another 200k
it's kind of work my point is there's a
level of discipline i've arrived at now
in terms of the things that i think
should be how they how i like companies
to be built
because otherwise you're always going to
be getting whipsawed
by the fun dynamics by
what lps are demanding of the gps by
what gps have
issues with with respect to compensation
and so there's a whole bunch of vagaries
that have nothing to do with you
well you know i'm building a house in
atherton i leased a fancy car
um yeah i'll do your deal um because i
think it's growing fast enough or
somebody else will mark up my deal
that'll allow me to raise a new fund
which will allow me to get the two
percent which will allow me to increase
my compensation which will pay for my
car
i'm sorry guys but like if you think
that that's not what's happening you're
lying to yourself
you are lying to yourself why are the
lps going along with this i'm curious
well some lps are actually unbelievably
superb
you know uh i'll publish this in my
letter but like we looked at a
composition of rlps and we're going to
kind of expose this so people see
but 80 of them are family offices and
they're exceptional
because they are like folks like us
they're kind of like grinders some of us
got lucky some
didn't then some got really lucky and
they're all pretty like low-key and
like they want they want to be around
people like us and it's wonderful
they're builders
they roll up your sleeves they're
builders and then they value building
and they don't value all the
high gloss veneer of um
service providers you know service
providers are very intoxicating because
they put a
high gloss veneer basically being a
parasitic
blood sucking piece of [ __ ] on on a
builder
um that's what i was gonna say
uh but uh anyway service providers aside
uh what the [ __ ] are you talking about
oh yeah um
the lps the good ones endowments kick
ass
uh foundations kick ass um
just because like like you know we have
a couple of foundations who do a ton of
stuff in medical research and
it's inspiring um we actually also
you know worked with uh a couple of
organizations that allowed the
pensioners
because we were like we knew we were
gonna make money i've always known
and i'm like i don't want to make money
for other rich people and i don't want
to make money for like
harvard like i want to make money for
like
pensioners who work in a non-profit
because like they're like yeah i'm going
to work at this hospital because i want
to help people
and it's so anyway so we have that and
then the the thing that i made a mistake
is uh
you know at one point in time uh i let
my partners choose a few of the lps
and uh you know they had a very
different set of incentives than i did
and we ended up
admitting a bunch of funda funds and uh
some were okay
but there were a few that were uh just
horrible horrible rotten people um
these the people that have in the press
anonymously
um i'm not sure i don't know because
these are all well to be honest with you
jason if i had to really internalize i
think a bunch of my former partners said
that as well like
at the end of the day i was tricking
myself and them
this was a benevolent dictatorship that
i tried to pretend was a democracy
and i should have just owned that
and it's not to say that it's right or
wrong but i had the right to start a
company the way i wanted
run my way with on my terms i have
earned that right
and i should have just been more honest
with everybody now was i honest in the
docs
that everybody signed yes was i honest
and when their lawyers who i paid for
reviewed the things that said uh he has
absolute control and can do whatever he
wants whenever he wants
was that honest yes but at the end of
the day i was still like guys it's a
community
you know let's work together it's nice i
like what you think yes
but then when push came to shop big
decisions i was like sorry we're doing
this sorry we're not doing it
right and uh that's not for everybody
and
it was for me and um yeah so you know
those guys really chaffed at that
yeah but yeah the people that were that
are sniping at the end of the day press
is there to basically you said this
incredibly well
you know it's about criticism
and criticism is two things the positive
way that i took criticism is what did i
do wrong and how do i make myself better
as a human being
and the takeaway from there is i made a
lot of people feel very unworthy and
unseen because of my style
and i have to be more coherent and
honest with my style and allow people to
choose whether to be around it or not
right but the second part which is
less about me and more about them is
like nobody remembers a critic
no and at the end of the day critics are
there to basically amplify
other people's frustration so you can
take the little bit of it that's
positive but otherwise
you gotta block it out i mean you guys
are trying to build things
that's so hard nobody believes it's so
dark you're all alone last thing you
want is someone telling you that you
can't do it like [ __ ] those people
especially if they're just doing it to
get paid views
it's like bottom feels they're like
anonymous irrelevant
losers on the sidelines you're on the
field doing things
be proud that's amazing that's
hard that's hard good for you
yeah uh yeah this one critic in the
history of critics who ever mattered it
was roger ebert
and the reason roger ebert was loved was
because he was a fan of
new directors new projects and he was
just this tremendous supporter of the
art of
cinema and it was and the other thing
that you said before which is true like
criticism really matters when you're
exposing
you know deep structural faults in a
system investigative journalists etc
that kind of criticism is important but
you know when you're talking about
swiping
when you're talking about sniping from
the sidelines about how
company a is screwed and company b is
screwed and oh my god this person lost
an executive and that person
and it's like you know nothing about
nothing about nothing because you're
sitting there in your dark little room
toiling away bitterly trying to be one
of us and you're not
that's what you're doing and those
people don't matter
no it's the people who make things that
matter uh well
on that uh
i'm gonna just deal with the fallout of
this conversation for a little while
wait what is the fallout of this
conversation this conversation was real
well no it was pretty it was very real i
think it is weird
no it's great because up until this
moment
people were more worried about elon than
you and now people are more worried
about you than elon's and that makes it
i'm joking you know what's so funny like
e and i will make it through all we are
the nuclear cockroaches he and i
exactly you know we will survive you
will survive absolutely
because you talked to him as well he's
like everything's great
everything's fantastic like cars are
going up into the right and people are
on
social media saying how much they love
the car what else is there it's crazy
like the product is loved it's the
greatest car ever made and people can't
get enough of them no we're both like
literally like it's like why does
everybody think things are so
and it's like again people want to
validate
page view click bait but it doesn't map
to like what's really happening
no the reality is far different all
right on that note
let's hear it for trump good luck here
good luck all you guys